Julia gasps five five I know I was a
good effort thank you to me - oh thank
you thanks
whoa new chairs guys we're in chairs
that are made for sitting in more than
five minutes and I like playing with it
I want to just play with my chair this
whole time like for those of you that
are listening and can't see they're like
gaming chairs yeah just a little
comfortable they're really comfortable I
think they're like economically designed
to fit your gaining body which is gaming
is an uncomfortable position yeah and
the other chairs I mean they're easy on
the eyes but not so much on the back
anyway welcome back to the Gennie's
William podcast this week's episode is
brought to you by headspace start
meditating for free on the app go to
headspace calm slash Jenna Julianne to
get on your way to a happier stress-free
lifestyle and do the take ten challenge
ten days free of meditating is also
brought to you by vice land vices new TV
channel with plenty of awesome new shows
coming out this week the channel
actually launches today so check that
out it is called vice land see we can
get the channel I actually watched one
of their new shows before came out so I
can tell you guys about we'll talk about
later it's called balls-deep
and it's a great show and they do some
of the most like entertaining pieces so
thank you to both of our sponsors Bryce
land on a head space so we're on new
chairs and I'm trying to like frame
right because like the other chairs they
stopped right here they weren't in the
frame but now you have to factor it in
to make sure it all those factors so
many factors if you have so many factors
are you are you in a factory - it's how
do we today I'm like super derpy you
ever just have like a dirt day we need
to steal their appeal with that Derby
Day
I feel Burpee also literally right
before I hit record I was like actually
I am hungry cuz I was like are you gonna
eat before we podcast he was like no I'm
good
and then I sat in this chair and then I
got hungry that sounds like something I
would do except they'd be a lot looser
everyone a lot worse for everyone
because I'm worse to be around one
hungry well yeah you're hangry when
you're hungry like a lot of times I'm
curious here is I get a hungry fury is
this
yeah it's hurry hurry I'm Seri absolute
here unleash hell Wow
like when we're travelling um with Rome
Rome knows Rome knows now at first you
know she was like Julian alright like he
seemed really upset this morning like
you know he's just hungry he really is
just hungry that's it she had a learning
curve but now it's like it's like
there's two Jenna's underselling Romo
Giuliani hi first thing you gotta do is
go find some food at the airport and we
don't mince words anymore Rome's not
like are you hungry I'm like oh no I'm
fine it doesn't do that anymore she's
like Julie I don't eat something yeah
let's just really give me some [ __ ]
food it's not your fault you have all
those muscle children to feed look at
them they're turning into muscle
teenagers too growing up and they're
just hungrier and hungrier they're
hungry so um today is a weird day we
like woke up it's a Saturday we podcast
it on Saturday this week normally
normally you do Thursday or Friday this
week we had to push it back but we woke
up on a Saturday and there's fights on
like midday we can Silva and Bisping we
can talk about that you want a brother
back so there's Anderson Silva fighting
Bisbing I feel some type of way about
that fight first of all Bisbing won and
he should have won so good call on the
judges which is very strongly about that
for all of you Anderson Silva fans out
there
Julien feels very strongly that Michael
visiting showed one he did win yes I
know yeah no he's earned the way it was
uh it was the most I've ever wanted
both Bisbing to win and so little loose
and I'm not I'm not a person who
dislikes Michael Disney
I've always liked Michael visiting a lot
of people I mean he prides him alone and
so many people have hated him for so
long but you like he starting to become
more light to because you have to
respect him he's like he's still
relevant and he's still really good and
he's
I actually met him in person which was
really cool but he's a very likable guy
if you look past his little you know his
whole thing he puts on anyway he fought
a great fight Herb Dean totally [ __ ]
the whole thing up there's an incident
where Michaels mouthpiece fell out and
he pointed to it twice and not only did
he not stopped the fight to get the
mouthpiece back in his mouth he he like
verbally responded to business so this
being looked at her being while her team
was talking to him and then got kneed in
the face it was very dirty and silver
shouldn't have even done it so I was
pissed but I was just glad that visiting
one yeah don't worry we're not gonna
talk about fights all podcast for the
next six podcasts will talk about this
one fight oh my god
does not deserve that many podcast yeah
he he deserved to win and I feel like
Anderson Silva's you know he looks like
a different person now when he fights he
doesn't look even close to the same yeah
and and that was Michael Bisping his
lifelong dream to fight him and he did
and got very emotional he and he
deserved to win because he was taking
the fight seriously and Anderson's elbow
was was not he was Anderson Silva in a
lot but he was doing it in like a sloppy
way too he just he didn't I mean nothing
about him looked at all like the old one
yeah but I couldn't be happier for
Bisbing I just feel bad for visiting
face because herb D knows him like the
medical bills involved in him getting
his face split open by them nasty me it
was a it was a dirty knee should have
happened again sorority should have been
like he was so far away across the
Octagon when it was happening and he was
holding this Vings mouth guard in his
hand yeah so Bisbing had you know there
was a second time and he was like are
you gonna give me my mouthpiece back and
Dean was standing across hacking at him
he should have been right up next to
them jumping in civvy that's what refs
do they have the mouth guard that it
picked up mid fight they'll jump in and
be like put this back in art fight
instead he just held it and he was
talking to this thing so business
distracted yeah which is really weird to
me well you know you never know what's
going on with herb Dean because that was
relatively out of character for him as a
referee yes and no he's had a lot of
really bad fuck-ups but he's also
sometimes a good rapid it's hard because
in MMA I really can't
I'm one guy who's been perfect Tim
Winslow I'm she's the best she's a god
amongst men no even like you know John
McCarthy or Dan Murg leotta or any any
Ref who's ever done a good job has also
done a horrible job that's just how it
works
it's Jim especially in MMA but it was
just a little weird watching Anderson on
a freed fight the right paths cartoon
wasn't freeze on fight past but still
the middle of the day it was only learn
ok I want to ask you a question because
we have not talked about this yet what
are your thoughts on a Conor McGregor
and Diaz okay so my thoughts on the
fight itself if you just look at it as a
match up I think it's a good fight I
personally think it's more interesting
than a potential dos Santos vs McGregor
fight simply because these guys are
going to box and that's cooler to watch
you know that like they both have a lot
of reach they both have very skilled
hands dos Santos would have onion Oh
undoubtedly tried to take Connor down
put him on his back in terms of like
this being the replacement fight I don't
think it could have been a better
replacement like if you think you know
who could have stepped up and put and
promoted a fight I'm always gonna agree
with that right like it you know people
are like upset that the fights next week
because they want to have more build-up
as a shock like that's how good of a
replacement a des is I just feel like
any time someone has to drop out of a
fight if you could fill it in with the
DS regardless of gender you're good
class like I'm kidding I'm totally
kidding just proponent of Diaz oh I just
love them because you know that I love
outspoken people that are yes they do
whatever they want good or bad and you
know they've dealt with the consequences
good and bad yeah both of them yeah I'm
just I'm stoked I'm so excited
cuz we literally have not talked about
that I am so excited yeah I chant we
haven't talked about it it's happening
this weekend March 5th super fight right
March 4 that isn't a Holly Holm fighting
yeah Holly Holm fighting means you take
like casually on the [ __ ]
Co main event and it was weird like dos
Anjos like broke his foot whatever
that's legit
dropped out and then he started [ __ ]
runnin his mouth on Twitter like oh of
course like you didn't want to fight
Donald Cerrone like what dude shut the
[ __ ] up right now you do not get to talk
you do not get to open your mouth at all
towards Conor McGregor you dropped out
of the fight there's no place for you to
eat I mean it was like the weirdest
thing that's so weird that was pretty
weird
ah do you have a prediction no I don't
yeah I predict that I will be thoroughly
entertained I guess if you had to twist
my arm
I would say that McGregor would probably
win but I think what oh you're twisting
it oh no give me a rope burn burn huh
well it's that it's a rope like an
Indian burn you racist I'm totally
kidding that's an India I'm so kidding
I'm sorry that's not meant to be
offensive that's just Wow okay ow oh wow
do you see this burn on my form yeah cuz
she burned herself on the stove I was
cooking moussaka and I got born massage
my prediction well the last time Dee
Nate Diaz got knocked out doing a kick
to the head by Josh Thompson hmm and he
never ever got got knocked out before
that I think Conor is gonna finish him
not with the submission I think he's
gonna knock him out TKO or knockout yeah
hmm Connors I mean he's - he's a [ __ ]
peak of his game when you watch the
ideas and you're like he goes up against
Michael Johnson and you're still
wondering is he gonna win his fight
that's when you're like okay he's on a
different level uncomplicated thing that
I'm gonna say though because I'm a I'm a
Diaz fan just regardless of anything
forever just as human beings I'm blood
both of them um I think that they
perform exceptionally well under
pressure so when they have all the
lights all of the big bright everything
happening the crowd they feed off of the
energy of other people in there so since
this is going to be a massive fight with
a lot of energy and a lot of people
watching and cheering and screaming and
it just feeds into what he's about like
you're right I think that you will see
although I do think that they owe
are in top condition top form they're
always they're always really like
athletes
yeah exactly they're always in great
shape I think that you will see a really
good fight from from Diaz because he's
just like ready to go when people are
yelling and screaming all right bigger
the higher the stakes the better they
fight I agree like I I I don't think
this is gonna be an easy fight at all
much to lose though we either that's the
thing all the pressures on Conor right
and I don't think Connors gonna have an
easy fight but I do think once the first
rounds over once all that energy kind of
just simmers down Conor's can dial
himself in and he's gonna really start
to hurt him that's what I think you me
oh I just predict that I'm gonna be
wildly entertained and that Nate's gonna
make me laugh well because you know
they're both going to be throwing the
bird at each other talking to me grandpa
Oh take my money dad take it and we
throw it you take my money like right
now okay what's your prediction for
Misha and Holly home because I'm I'm
gonna predict the Misha is not gonna win
that fight pitch me just [ __ ] chill
I'm a hell of a fight the thing about
Misha is she is the single toughest
fighter [ __ ] yeah
by far in the female division but even
yeah one of the toughest in the US hold
on I was shot by a page it but she
fights at 115 fans yeah yeah and uh also
rose Nami units yeah oh my god well she
beat her my girl thug roses always been
like dope she's just been you know young
and finding her her stride but well she
when she Peaks everybody did every
scared face that's a different way about
115 so you know I'm just but Miesha Tate
hmm okay Miesha Tate has been uh signing
the fight changes for canceled yes
awesome we're gonna give me a half wait
that's the athlete Coe hair um so Misha
has been in the fight game forever but
what I mean she's a talented she's a
well-rounded fighter you know ironing
she can grapple she can kick box she can
you know wrestle but there's one thing
that separates her from so many people
is our [ __ ]
toughness like she can take punch after
punch she can look like horrible after a
fight she's taking so much damage but
caps going so I think that if she can
withstand the punches and kicks that
Ronda couldn't which I do think that is
the thing I think media has a better
and toughness and Rhonda she can likes
mother Holle home late in the fight and
wrestle her and beat her up on the
ground have you ever seen Holly Holm
grapple
she can't grapple I mean she trains at
Jackson's MMA
she knows basic grappling but she's a
kickboxer true do you think well because
I think if the fight would stay it on
their feet that Holly would win but if
Misha got her on the ground do you think
that she stands a chance well what does
stand a chance me like this she I'm
asking you do you think Misha stands a
chance to submit her absolutely I think
I think Holly only stands a chance on
the ground it's surviving she's not
going to attack off her bat she's not
gonna submit she you know she might
escape and get back to her feet but if
if we she can find a way to wrestle
really well and use ground and pound
and maybe you know threatened with
submissions she's going to be running
the fight whereas on her feet Holly's
gonna be dictated the fight hmm she
can't fight either way I think it's even
you know more interesting matchup than
the Ronda fight I get really upset I'll
say this as that's what we hold on right
after Ronda loss we went on the podcast
and talked about right and you were like
this is so good for the whole division I
was like this is good for Misha tape
this is the best thing you could not
resent a strip club being like I'm the
person that should get this fight in
dangerous right it was it was a strip
club she was a gentleman for a nightclub
watching the Holly Holm fight she was
getting paid to be there like do you me
sure you doing party slay queen it was
it was in Vegas so it's yeah they have
all sorts of weird after parties or
viewing parties it was a viewing party
at a gentlemen's club which I don't
think is out of out of character for me
yes no nor does I nor do I think that
that reflects poorly on me sure it's
just a place to host a night you okay
for sure for sure um but I yes you did
say that but I also want to say that I
get extremely frustrated watching fights
when I feel like the person that is
losing doesn't quite have a plan of how
they want to win like I was getting
frustrated in the Ronda Rousey fight
because well against Holly Holm because
Holly was you know just in and out in
and out out just attacking her with
punches and Ronda needed to get her ass
on the [ __ ] ground but it didn't look
like she
percent had a goal I think that's a bad
example but there are so many shades
rockso earlier is more of just surviving
there are so many fights where someone's
losing and you're like dude what's your
[ __ ] plan why do you not have a plan
I think they were preparation yeah when
Misha fights Holly her plan will be from
beginning to end because you know how
many she fights her plan will be to get
her on the ground
make her can grapple her to death get
her to [ __ ] standing choke wrap her
little legs around Holly Holm and
squeeze her like a Python
and I think that that is a good plan
because you're not going to go in there
and box with her yeah you know yeah I
mean I mean Misha is the the one I would
the one female 135 or that I would pick
against Holly right now because she's
she's so around she can wrestle like
crazy she can grapple and she can pop
you know stand on her feet and survive
cyborg those the hero we need I'm
kidding I mean it's just over cyborg I
just like saying curse cyborg and I love
that gift of betch go hey oh so sorry
for not really contributing to the
conference i fishing now you can do
reading I just think Misha's uh she's
she's good matchup for Holly I agree I
think is gonna be really good fight I
mean I'm Ally fan and I'm a Misha fee if
I were picking out I'm you know if I I
put money on the fight it's gonna be on
Misha that's who I pick me easily oh
yeah I pick me Shin this fight Wow
goalie I would not be mad at all Misha
had a title under I mean she deserves
she rich yeah dude I mean it's but he
only deserves healthier one whatever but
she just deserves a shot I'm happy she's
getting it I agree
um so fights
who else is fighting that night on the
super fight I have to look at the card
it's not a super fight it was just gonna
be a really dumb card fight Emily up
yeah look it up huh just has Nathan
saying anything on Twitter are like when
you periscope sometimes and it's just
like up nothing
Nick posted a little like meme thing of
Conor and it's it's a picture of Conor
with with the Mike and he's saying I
don't care about a [ __ ] belt and then
Nate needs pictures there and Nate says
why do you always carry around and then
Connor is just like
and that happened to the press
conference but Nick and Nate in their in
their [ __ ] getting Instagram trash
talk I love it I love both of them Oh
funny as [ __ ] hold on superfight is it
190 very fight I'm not sure
196 yeah McGregor Diaz um I wonder
what's making that noise you hear them
the hum yeah they might be the computer
you wanna just like shove it really
quick how do you know it's not a
bumblebee it's probably a bumblebee Oh
hmm nope wasn't that oh you know it is
what lights the lights that we got the
hue lights in here and we haven't set
them up yet so they're making that weird
[ __ ] Oh [ __ ] that's what it
is ear Latifi is fighting Gian Villante
or I think that's how you say it Korie
engines fighting Tom Lawlor Tom Lawlor
where's he been Amanda Nunez Brandon
thatch Erik Silva yeah it's not a super
stats card it was really about the main
in the coming I'm excited
Oh Jim Miller is casually fighting Diego
Sanchez I like that did you know that
Floyd Mayweather I heard I didn't read
into this at all but someone introduced
I was talking about that he is building
a fighter arena a Floyd Mayweather and
we're well in Vegas and it's supposedly
going to be bigger than the MGM and it's
gonna house UFC fights as well as boxing
so if you've noticed you know if you've
noticed in the last couple months Floyd
hasn't been running his mouth bottom MA
I mean it's been pretty apparent if you
would do that a lot and now he's not
yeah you can't beat them join him
right there's money you know I mean
there's no beating MMA or boxing you
guys are both winning but it's a
business it's a good business
opportunity to build a [ __ ] official
arena in Vegas instead of knowing it if
you're employed moneymaker no spaces you
have the money to do it to [ __ ] do it
he probably just dropped one of his
duffle bags and was like all right guys
just start working on it just somebody
draw something maybe a duffel bag and a
half it's bigger than them gym so but he
does carry on those duffle bags that's
so weird that he does that yeah it is
he's a stand-up guy
no he's not I remember years ago when I
was blogging he tweeted a picture of him
remember like the first generation iPod
yes oh we linked the physical wheel yeah
and then there was the second generation
one that was still had the physical
click wheel but it was just a little bit
smaller there's a picture of him that he
had tweeted like that year when that was
a thing yeah of it a diamond necklace
shaped like that 2nd generation iPod
just like covered in diamonds and it was
really funny and I blogged about it oh
you did oh that's fine because I
remember like my boss was pissed at me
you know Suzy was like where'd you find
that I'm like on his Twitter he's like
you follow Floyd Mayweather and Twitter
and work you living it was really funny
though I want to find it now because I'm
sure even funnier in hindsight that you
have like an outdated technology
encrusted in diamonds around your neck
you know encrusted yeah just you know
just in case you're wondering about
covering your Tamagotchi and diamonds
are your Cassiel calculator watch and
diamond yeah mmm be a set VHS and
diamonds oh yeah but then it wouldn't
work it's not functional VHS Sega
diamond Sega Dreamcast
diamond gayboy Gameboy it sounds like
game boy said gabriel a Wow
toodaloo gay boys was that from I don't
know what movie is that from The
Hangover I think Oh
ken ken Jeong I think are you so funny
man right jo je ong honor I'm not sure
you know what you could do you can get
it diamond-encrusted TV and you put it
all on the perimeter right you put the
Diamonds all on the top on the bottom
all on the side and even on the back but
not on the screen because on the screen
you're gonna be watching bison ices
brand new TV channel with awesome new
shows like I said there's a whole lineup
of brand new shows for you guys to watch
and if you ever watched something from
vice it is like on another level
documentary wise and you know
cinematically just the stories they tell
i watch a lot of that we watch a lot of
ice but vice land is now a TV channel
that's gonna house all of these new
shows and i watch the show lighting oh
my god so you know the little mousie guy
Thomas Morton so he hosts a new show
called balls-deep and in this show he
basically goes it's it's a very simple
concept he wants to explore different
parts of the world and live how those
people live that's not it's very
bare-bones you know but the idea it
isn't what makes it special it's how
they execute it so he goes for this
episode I want a special guy he's very
funny
so he goes to this town in Arkansas
where they have these tent revivals but
Jesus
crazy like very intense Christian tent
revivals like okay where they have these
uh I don't you know it's hard to explain
but they have these ceremonies where I
don't really I don't really know what to
say exactly to describe it but it's a
it's a very religious thing that they do
in these big tents outside and it's
intense because it's not just like a
normal church service but it's like I
think energy you don't talk about yeah
um I forget who was doing it one of the
big I can't remember
um televangelists you know yeah and then
they had like a retreat or something and
they put him in the big tent yeah
superhot in there and yeah it's crazy
high and then someone's laying on the
floor and they're like yelling at him
and they're trying to like do this horse
cool so that's the first episode so yeah
that's that I don't know if it's the
person the first one i watch but that
isn't it might be the first episode of
balls deep with Thomas Warren and
basically he goes in and he helps out
he's part of it and this whole time
you're like getting his take on
everything which is the great thing
about him is he's able to not be rude or
judgmental but he's also able to give
you like you know his straight-up
opinion of things to the camera and
straight to other people's faces without
being a certain way he's very like
friendly and he does it in a very
interesting way it's incredibly
entertaining um that's so cool so if you
guys are interested in that awesome kind
of stuff and they have plenty of other
shows as a show about stand-up comedians
it's a lot of cool cool lineup of shows
coming up on my watch vise or know what
that is that it's incredible they have
so many documentaries and even if you
like because we watch them on Xbox video
don't be oh go and stuff like that but
if you don't have that now it's a
channel to use an inch even it's the
topic of it because when I forced Julian
to watch them sometimes you know the
topic might not seem interesting to him
so he'll keep moving I'm like no it
doesn't matter they better turn it on
and start watching it and you will be
into it that's that's vice for you -
yeah they do a really good job of that
so I'm check it out
vise land um it's a new channel and next
so it actually launches today so the
show I was talking about balls-deep
premieres March 2nd at 11 p.m. on
Priceline also thanks again to headspace
we've talked about headspace before its
base is basically an app you take on
your phone tablet computer and it
basically once you plug in some
headphones allows you to meditate
wherever you are and it's guided
meditation so you're not just left to
just do it how you think they really
really help you they give you a lot of
key tips and how you're supposed to
meditate for the best results meditation
you know it's it's rooted I always say
this is rooted in thousands of years of
science and also tradition and it works
it does reduce stress it does help you
with your relationships it has a number
of amazing benefits but if you go to
headspace calm / gentle gently right now
you can do the take 10 challenge which
means you can meditate 10 days for free
all guided all
through the program and see how you like
it but that whole trial is going to suck
you in you're going to want to do more
so check that out my head space is
really great
you can do it anytime guys just bring
your headphones and your phone and you
are set to go yeah if anything if
anything just use it to relax and slow
down the time you don't even realize
what ten minutes can do when you when
you're really focusing on meditating
like that although it's a you know
you're only here for so long just slow
down the time just enjoy your time here
on it's a great way to play good
headspace are calm / Jenna Julian you
get served thanks to our sponsors thank
you sponsors um so as you guys are
witnessing right now it's pretty pretty
relaxed off-the-cuff podcast because we
we figured we'd throw one of these in
because they're fun them cuz they're fun
they're fun all the time
oh yeah I am fun I'm fun guy Wow doing
one guy we we actually don't have a game
idea to play well someone suggested it
to me and it made me laugh out loud I
can't remember I did a screenshot of it
um I'll try and find it but I'm probably
not going to I can't remember who it was
on Twitter or Facebook but someone was
like my husband and I like to play this
game where we pick a person and we
decide whether or not they're a fruit or
a vegetable and like what fruit or
vegetable they would be in shoes like we
call it fruit or vegetable she was like
so for example like if Kermit marbles
and peach were a fruit or vegetable what
would they be and why I thought it was
[ __ ] funny it's funny I think we
should do I already we already have
lists of names so I want to start with
you okay Amaya fruit or vegetable what
do you think no no no you gotta tell me
if I'm a fruit or a vegetable okay I
want to think of like ooh okay I think
that you would be a fruit and uh that
you would be a pineapple because you're
really sweet on the inside and you're
like strong and hard on the outs
but you also have a fancy hat and like
your hair is really pretty but your
don't [ __ ] touch me though you'll get
pricked but you also grow close to the
ground because you're grounded person in
you're a nice person
oh good I think you're a pineapple I
appreciate that
hello so how's a like pineapple a lot
it's delicious it's for adores was
really good
what am I am i f ruder image stuff hmm
no I know what peaches peaches of hurt
she's peachy she's a peach what's
marbles fruit or vegetable ah vegetable
he is a pepper a fiery hot pepper oh
he's my little pepper he's little pepper
my lil Pepito you so cute Kermit though
Kermit is a tomato because he's a fruit
but he looks like a vegetable I was
gonna say that he's like a cucumber or
something he's just like kind of weird
so weird it's just a little nervous to
be here yeah is the tomato well isn't it
tomato a fruit technically but everyone
thinks it's a veggie yeah so that's what
come is yeah and avocado is - it's a
fruit yeah well Kermit's better than an
avocado ah be better cotton enough look
you know that's not a bad ghost Logan to
live by huh be better than you know
we're better than an avocado better than
an avocado um I think you are definitely
um probably you know I think your
carrots
I'm carrots I think I can because
carrots grow out of the ground like
literally yeah yeah no but you've come
out of God that's where you grow you
don't grow on trees you're so close to
the ground you were the most grounded
person I know you were very good at like
how do I say this you know I'm saying
like I'm all over the place sometimes
but you're like wait a minute let's just
be grounded for a second pointed into
the ground yeah what's your sign I'm a
very good yeah that has no what's your
sign
Aries girl Oh for those of you that are
fans of astrology you'd know the Julian
and I don't typically date virgos and
Aries don't typically romantically
linked up but [ __ ] all that [ __ ] I like
astrology when it's good for me
Thank You astrology when it's like oh
you guys shouldn't date I'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is a bunch of horseshit I know
it's like oh you guys they're destined
to be together
yeah [ __ ] love this [ __ ] I'm kidding
but true you're you're an Aries big time
um I'm very she's an air sign he's all
over the place and I'm an earth sign I
like to stay at home and be grounded
ground myself yeah I'm grounded
daddy you grounded you're grounded okay
yeah Jenya grounded um what do you think
Donald Trump is no not talking about him
I want to know if he's a fruit or a
vegetable he's a plant the Venus flytrap
cuz he just opens his mouth that is not
a fruit or veg
I know what's Ryan Higa oh I got a good
answer for him I think yeah I think yeah
I think Ryan would be I see I think
Ryan's a cucumber I think Ryan's a
butternut-squash why because it's shaped
like the base of a lamp oh yeah yeah I
think the point of the game though is to
just decide whether or not so I'm just
right away like a vegetable like Ryan is
more vegetable like I think he's a
vegetable he's definitely a vegetable
he's a vegetable
yeah he's like cool he's chilling guys
like creamed corn that's not a vegetable
that's there's a vegetable dish corn is
a vegetarian corn creamed spinach
collard greens collard greens are
vegetable I think creamed corn right why
well because he's like a vegetable right
it's like it's like corn yeah but it's
creamed corn so it's like all right this
is fun what the [ __ ] it's fun okay who
else you got what now judge Hawkins
Donald Trump let's go back to Tom Trump
I already did
yeah fruit a vegetable he's not a Venus
flytrap okay he's a fruit but like I
think he's a tomato
he's an avocado he's a tomato Kermit's a
tomato hermits nada told me tomato he's
a cucumber Donald Trump he's I don't
know he's he's uh he's a tomato I mean
if anything just look at his face he's
just red that's true all right he's the
man he's got orange he could be a
pumpkin no pumpkins are way cooler than
him all right what's Kanye oh okay um
let me think about it well just decide
fruit or vegetable is he a fruit or a
vegetable definitely best part I feel
like he's a fruit like he's a strong
flavored fruit or he's at least like a
like a really strongly flavored yeah
he's a pickle an onion he's a pickle a
pickle is not a vegetable ito cucumber
no okay he took he was a he was a
cucumber yeah and he was like in this
vinegar for so long okay so do you want
to play the game what food are people no
no we're doing fritter vegetable a
pickle is not a vegetable pickle is a
vegetable it's a modified vegetable
that's it so when you eat a pickle what
are you eating
is that a carb is that is that like a
piece of meat is the food all right fine
fruit a vegetable only you don't get to
do modified fine you can say if they're
fruit or vegetable then say what dish
you think thing I think he's into art
and onions a good one because he's an
intense vegetable he's an intense
vegetable is that fair yeah okay dry for
sure all right where you go Hillary
Clinton hmm I got in I say fruit - I was
gonna say like papaya
yeah good but those are similar yeah but
you're like it's got that flavor you're
we're like I'm not 100% sure if I like
this yeah like it's a fruit you should
strange texture yeah and you go and it's
got benefits to it like it's got like
potassium stuff but it doesn't taste
like it smells okay but it doesn't taste
as good as you wanted to yeah yeah and
she's afraid she's for searching for you
for sure
I was good one Jeff Probst ooh
props Maga
Oh Julian wins immunity
speaking of which if we could get if we
could get a survivor contestant on the
show would you guys oh we can I
absolutely look into that we actually
have a couple of ways to do it with a
couple of different people so leave in
the comments if you like that you want
that because we will reach out to the
movie job then make it happen
um I'm obsessed with Cochran I would
dive she's one of the possibilities cuz
he hit me up before I'm actually drops
by his periscope on time and icon Terry
and he noticed me stalker and apparently
he knows who we are so I mean I have
some favorites off of Survivor like all
time that I've stalked on sup anyways so
I should stock them - I don't follow any
of them I should look them up I stop
every black it's not conquer but no one
else and you look up ah
I stuck Spenser I stuck the [ __ ] out his
funding loves that sir I do cuz he
reminds me of my brother he's very he's
very much like your brother yeah and who
else
who was that what's-his-face on the the
last season with the glasses I love him
I love this season on the glasses what's
his name Kai
oh yeah he's he's hilarious
awesome oh he's Vietnamese Vietnamese
I'm sorry yeah no you're right he grew
up in Vietnam Yeah right
I can't hundred cent remember he lived
in Vietnam at some point anyways fruit
or vegetable fruit vegetable jeff probst
he's definitely vegetable come on hmm
dude he is so even keeled okay I would
say that Jeff Probst is like like a
parsnip there's like a white carrot sort
of thing hmm
parsnip you know what I think Jess
prompted I think he's jicama jicama
that's a good one is jicama a vegetable
oh you know might be fruit I don't know
whatever you know what if it's a fruit
that's even better because it's like the
most it's the most even killed forest
and when you cut it it goes ooh
yeah sure props is amazing because he
has here's this arsenal of like 15
different phrases that he's repeated for
years and never ever says them even
closely differently like it's it blows
my mind how good he is at that yeah he
is really good evening why have you sin
has and yeah and like when I went I went
to school for for that kind of thing
like people who were in my major wanted
to be TV host they wanted to be TV
reporters and you had to learn how to do
that you had to say the same thing the
same way every time and it's [ __ ]
hard and it's really weird and
everything there's always different
factors and to think about the
extremities wow that was the wrong word
to think about the extreme conditions
not the arms and legs of being on
Survivor and hosting all the time and
still performing and doing that right
being that host it's crazy it's insane
so jicama mmm and when you cut it it
also goes we you just said that we only
do three seconds dip it in the fire get
fired fire represents your life
hey come on roots that represents your
life and about this is a jicama
all right you ready on the count of
three you have to start it just say a
famous Jeff Probst thing until you can't
anymore and I will take turns ready go
Julian wins immunity good I got nothing
for you
come on in guys no oh don't do this uh
bring me your torch
that's good Flint in the form of fire
ooh why don't you play for that worth
playing flesh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh God um
let me think real quick it is time to
vote
take a look at the new tribe Wow
drop your buffs Johnny wins reward
oh [ __ ] skid 'ln um welcome to the
survive
action all right I give up you one SMO
you definitely one I was taking too much
I was a fun game
yeah it's Jeff Probst quotes game oh
yeah I feel like we're missing like a
really important one that I can't think
of Horus great [ __ ] try to smoke in try
this one that one Jenna way to go damn
sounds good good stuff yeah but yeah he
really does say the same stuff yeah he's
great he's he's pretty legend okay
anyways back to Prudhoe Bay that's where
you want do a couple more mister couple
more okay hold on oh please it my turn
you know I don't Guy Fieri oh okay um
Guy Fieri I mean a buffalo wing has got
a fruit vegetable so we can't pick that
hmm a ghost pepper ghost that's pretty
funny cuz he's just like way too hot for
anybody to eat what what is um what's
the closest thing to cotton that's
edible hmm that's a fruit or vegetable
yeah I guess I was just thinking what
will you make napkins out of that sky
furies he uses napkins all the time
because he's filthy
oh okay so he's a tree no no no he's an
acorn he's a dragon fruit cuz that's
what he looks like
oh right fair enough spiked last until
oh now I'm the same as Guy Fieri this is
a fun podcast oh my god
nananananana I'm sorry I'm done so okay
what about me think who doesn't have
their list I don't want to open him up
on my phone but I wrote a bunch of them
what a Barack Obama ooh
what's he huh it's like he's celery
who he's tall salary's tall and he's
chill and he's got a good little crunch
I can't argue with that that's perfect
right he's got a good little crunch oh I
know what Michelle Obama's a sweet
potato yeah with good arms
remember that vine of her bulik sweet
potato no oh I guess I missed the joke
then in Rick Ross's pears perv now is
this whole podcasters just turned into a
vine apparently uh what what's Jaden
Smith hmm I like Jane said I think he's
neither afraid or vegetable because none
of those things exist exactly he is
neither a fruit in origin doesn't either
things exist in there you go what Shia
LaBeouf okay that's good he is um [ __ ] I
uh buff is a painting of a vegetable no
Shia LaBeouf is a vegetable painting
another vegetable in an elevator is a
ukulele playing a vegetable in medieval
you have a fruit that's made in he's
just riding it up and down when he did
that it reminded me of uh when I lived
in a dorm in school I only lived in a
dorm for one year but there are 11
floors and like you know Friday and
Saturday nights like we never did
anything for the most part because we
had the 24-hour like no drugs or not
that we did [ __ ] drugs
no no drinking is what I mean to say
like what you couldn't drink within
24-48 hours
of a practice or again this means like
never yeah so Friday night Saturday
nights we would stay in so you'd see all
the kids in the dorm yeah [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] and there was this one kid in our
dorm building which was 11 [ __ ]
floors and he would sit in the elevator
with his guitar and play songs so as
like people came in and out of the
elevator he would just be in there
playing [ __ ] Dave Matthews and [ __ ]
like dude can you get the [ __ ] out yes
those are the kids I just hated yeah and
then there'd be like a bunch of people
in there sitting with him and I'm like
why can't you go to your room like why
do you need to be in the elevator
why horrible but sheis was different I
guess yeah cuz he wasn't just doing
shitty Dave Matthews Band covers in the
elevator
yeah he was just meeting people
apparently he's not a friend's girl but
like you know you don't have to make
friend it was post on reddit that
someone was like I met Ryan an elevator
and then the comments it was like whoa
vishaya doing an elevator and they
explained it and he was like yeah he was
really nice guy and sometimes people
portrayed people in the media to be
weirder than they are and then someone
was like yeah he's just a totally normal
guy riding an elevator for 24 hours mmm
funny well if you want to wrap up we can
wrap it up but I wanted to say something
really quick really exciting news as of
right now guys we have a website we do
yeah it's up Jenna Julianne podcast.com
it's in love is live oh my god we did
it's been live since Friday we did a
soft launch on Friday and now
you guys can go to Jen and Julie and
podcast comm catch all the episodes in
one place that's our twitter or
instagram feed there's a store merch
store on there with all the stuff we've
been teasing and we are currently
working like always on the website we're
going to constantly improve it make
things have better about if you guys
have suggestions about the website you
go to it let us know on twitter at jenna
julian pod we're getting help on twitter
now debbie machine is helping us with
that twitter account so if you want to
tweet it that account you'll either get
one of us or Debian either way yeah
either way check out the podcast website
that's Jenna Julianne podcast so cool
calm and let us know what you think
hopefully you enjoy it yeah we do want
to make it like what you guys we want to
make it what you want so if there's a
feature that we don't have constructive
feedback is always welcome yeah because
we want to make it the best we can so
check that out guys and thank you again
for joining us another week of the
progress I like fun relax but this is a
fun one shot how did you get too serious
yeah no you right sometimes we do we do
and it's good to chill out frilly things
up chill out for a little bit if you're
not showing on podcasting you'll be
chilling out and meditating guided on
head scheduling that's head space.com
slash Jenna Julianne go check it out get
the app and see what you've been missing
guys stress free life it's amazing it
really does make a difference
Thank You headspace for sponsoring our
podcast and vice land the new TV channel
from vice with all new original shows
launching today uh check it out guys
right after you go to our website of
Iceland seriously go devices inside
space and download that yeah we'll just
have the best day and uh thanks again
vice land advice for sponsoring a
podcast we really think you guys are
going to enjoy some of those programs
because Vice really really makes quality
stuff yeah very thought-provoking if you
like this podcast you would like that a
lot more and honestly as someone who's
getting so interested in filmmaking
I find all of their projects all their
documentaries all their series so
interesting and so fulfilling because
they do they do such cool like
obviously a substantial work but it's
visually interesting cool trip now it's
awesome
anyway thanks guys for hanging out we
will catch you next week
Dave dink catch you next week dink them
on another podcast catch you tonight on
the twitch stream and uh have a great
week
finding